on va parler internet réseaux sociaux
vous êtes présents eric sur les réseaux
sociaux oui enfin forcément facebook
instagram c'est pas moi qui le gère mais
j'ai vu ça sur votre site internet dans
les rails fermeture tout à l'heure et
vous franck géant facebook ouais
d'accord ok typhaine est là plus qu'un
facebook elle est connectée hyper
branché et c est il ce matin va nous
parler d'amour en cinq lettres qui a
envahi les réseaux sociaux depuis
quelques années déjà éric est ce que
vous connaissez le mode franck c'est un
questionnement pas et vous franck franck
qu'est ce que ça veut dire prendre huit
mois p r à n car pour être très précis
alors prince et de l'anglais ça veut
dire un tour une farce alors en français
on dit prendre et si vous entendez les
ados les enfants prononcer ce mot méfiez
vous il prépare sûrement un mauvais coup
et par extension est bien le mot prend
qui est devenu aussi le nom de ces
vidéos que l'on filmé pour filmer bien
les gens à qui on a fait une farce à qui
on a préparé et bien un petit piège
alors qu'il s'agisse de proches ou de
parfaits inconnus d'accord en fait c'est
un peu la version moderne
si j'ai bien compris de vidéo gag quoi
c'est un peu un max de canut l'heure
c'est ça oui exactement alors imaginez
des enfants qui vont remplacer et bien
la chantilly par de la mousse à raser ou
les céréales dans la boîte par des
croquettes alors les enfants à youtube
heures déborde d'idées et les autres
enfants et 20 file voir les vidéos dès
qu'ils ont le temps mais vous oubliez le
caméscope de papy la bande qui crachote
et tout ça ce sont des vidéos de grande
qualité en général films et aux
smartphones avec montage effets spéciaux
et tout ce qui s'ensuit
alors on a trouvé des gens qui font des
fringues en bourgogne franche comté
figurez vous et les premiers dangereux
et vous parlez s'appelle les bodyguard
et les 21 ans ils sont bidons temps il
s'appelle maël et arthur et ils sont
bien longtemps mais ils ont choisi dijon
comme terrain de jeu alors il s'habille
tout en noir et les accoste les passants
pour les prendre à partie sur un sujet
ou un autre on lorsqu'on va faire je
pense que j'en pensais franck eric il
avait allez vous tous c'est peut-être
qu'on va regarder un extrait 1 ça me
semble logique on est sur internet on y
va on regarde un petit extrait attention
c'est très court il faut il faut être
vraiment au dessus au dessus inséré au
14e degré 1 on y va pour le premier
extrait vous avez peut-être eu quelqu'un
m'entende
non maintenant reviendrait pas fini mais
alors tu vas où je t'ai dit j'ai besoin
d'un remontant marche pas trop vite
sinon on va être obligé de te suivre
vraiment dommage bon bah ça c'est un
premier extrait j'ai du mal à voir le
vos souris
s'est pas vu
on s'interroge un petit fait non on
regarde le deuxième extrait puis vous
nous parler après de l'histoire ou vous
préférez vous dire un petit mot sur ce
premier extrait déjà comme vous voulez
en fait les vidéos compile pas mal de da
postroff comme ça de passants et donc
vous comprenez l'histoire au fur et à
mesure il faut regarder la vidéo dans
son ensemble et puis ensuite la réaction
des passants évidemment quand ils
comprennent que ils ont été piégés et
classement assez soulagé finalement mais
oui on peut regarder un deuxième extrait
allez on y va une nouvelle couche pour
sourire espérant le c'est parti c'est
sur internet je vais pour l'inscription
donc j'ai pris un corner quelqu'un de
votre magasin c'est pas normal que ça
s'effrite d'accord
d'accord c'est vraiment pas normal que
ce cirque question classe s'il vous
plaît je voudrais juste une petite glace
au chocolat
fabien granit et
bien granit et évidemment pour moi qui
suis de génération jean yves lafesse ou
laurent baffie oui voilà c'est ça oui
c'est un peu ça aussi bon c'est pas le
même niveau mais il commet ce qu'on va
dire c'est soit ça fait le buzz sur sur
la bourgogne franche comté et un peu
partout puis les plus jeunes connaissent
pas la génération pleine d'inconnues à
tiphaine ça exactement eux il faut voir
qu'ils ont lancé leur chaîne youtube ya
un an seulement parce qu'ils
connaissaient pas d'autres bourguignons
qui faisait des points qu est que eux
ils sont hyper fan de ça alors il vous
fait une quarantaine de vidéos et ils
m'ont dit que en fait ça leur permettait
de ma d'améliorer un peu leur jeu
d'acteur et qu'ils aimeraient peut-être
un jour est bien réalisé un court
métrage alors évidemment à tout ça est
en rodage mais moi je trouve que quand
même les passants sont assez impassible
je sais pas si je réussirai à être assez
calme alors maintenant qu'on sait que
s'il ya une caméra etc c'est sûr quand
je dis j'ai pas bien compris mais quand
on est pris dans le truck les fois où
vous savez on peut se faire piéger un
méfiance il ya d'autres personnes chez
nous et notamment à franc comtois qui
réalisent des des petites vidéos comme
ça ce genre de choses est lui aussi fait
le buzz tiffen oui s'appelle marouane
sista ailier du jamel comedy club alors
lui il a beaucoup plus d'audience 1
puisqu'il a je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte 629 mille abonnés sur tik
tok 41000 sur instagram et il ya
certaines de ses vidéos notamment sur le
port du masque qui ont fait 2 pardon qui
ont fait 20 millions de vues j'allais
dire de millions mais loin 20 millions
de vues alors lui il a vraiment le chic
par contre pour pour attirer l'attention
et captivé les gens qu'ils regardent sur
les réseaux sociaux là bas nous on aime
le garçon s'appelle marouane sista on
peut peut-être regarder un petit extrait
non malaisie allez on y va c'est parti
[Musique]
les princes version marouane sista voilà
ça peut faire sourire en tout cas ça
laisse pas insensible et ça fonctionne
sur les réseaux sociaux oui ça
fonctionne en plus il tourne à dijon à
montbéliard à besançon et il s'attaque
quand même à des petits sujets de
société en sa dernière vidéo publiée la
semaine dernière consistait à crier
attention voilà la police / 1 points de
deal de drogue donc je vous laisse
imaginer la réaction des dealers et puis
ça permet de montrer quand même des
petites questions de société ou des
comportements qu'on a mal a par exemple
les caisses automatiques
voilà des petites choses qui sont pas si
anodine finalement donc les planches ne
sont pas toujours dans des vidéos si
elle me dit que ça va on a noté et on a
appris surtout un nouveau mot en anglais
prennent qu'un canular ou farce
c'est né aux états-unis paraît-il en
2012 et c'est apparues sur youtube en
2016 voila voila on tente à ses proches
de faire croire qu'on a par exemple un
faux tatouage ou un faux piercings
paraît que voilà ça aussi c'est un
prince